[Music]
and fucked-up greed new scream green 380
greed submitted by Tangela is like
Angela a man has been sentenced to
prison for a baby food extortion scheme
whoa like he's depriving babies from
baby food I thought she was eating baby
but he was getting a baby food for he
was eating babies I thought he was
extorting babies for food baby food
extortion what's the dealio was he
extorting money or he was he was
extorting baby food money from baby food
companies Oh like if you don't give me
money I'm gonna top you play pub let in
this baby food no not tell I'm gonna
poison this baby food oh [ __ ] well why
don't you just poison him why didn't
they just fire him ya know so this man
was anonymously telling these baby food
companies like hey you need to pay me or
else I'm going to start poisoning your
food
how does even have access to the supply
chain well it's just like an anonymous
employee what he ended up doing was
painting baby food and then placing them
in super on supermarket shelves the
babies get affected to my knowledge no
one but you know if the thing is like
it's already open yeah yeah yeah we've
all Danny this takes place in southern
Germany oh they might have different
he was extorting thirteen point five
million dollars in order like he said
I'll identify myself if you give me this
yeah right right you should have been
like sorry dude I only have cash can you
meet me in person
I'd go for it do that he was [ __ ] yeah
do that what anything not even just baby
food everyone for it no yeah so he was
it was twenty kinds of food she was
threatening twenty different types of
food I hope it was a vegetable one
because those don't get bought that much
yeah they do they get by them ha ha ha
so you're looking at type of food are
you supposed to start them with the
vegetable ones so it cuz if you start
them with the fruit ones it's too sweet
and they don't want to do the vegetable
no they don't want to do it eventually
I loved broccoli that was my favorite
food when I was a kid
Isaac too and carrots yeah oh yeah they
were like pizza or broccoli I'm like
broccoli every time
Tiger likes carrots right but if I show
him a cinnamon toast crunch fits that
shit'll goal he knows what's up you love
cinnamon stats that sugar yeah his ass
can't talk but he knows how to
communicate he wants it so there dude
this 54 year old man he admitted to
placing five jars of tainted baby food
on supermarket shelves just five and the
jars were laced with ethylene glycol
which is a colorless and odorless liquid
that's used in antifreeze
yeah the sweet taste and it's awesome
often accidentally or intentionally
ingested and it can be very fatal to
humans it's crazy how do they know it's
sweet tasting someone's tried it right
it's right before they died so they
didn't give him the money
oh yeah it's sweet and then they died
there were a lot of yeah
write it down shut that down put on the
floor Helen hands came like a technique
my view is sweet that's a good technique
yeah we [ __ ] up yeah so there were
hundreds of people that called in tips
to the police on this special hotline
because they were trying to find out who
this person was and then that something
that led authorities to find additional
ethylene glycol at this man's residence
and
aside from the money they don't really
know what motivated how did they find
him so hundreds of people were just
ratting on me I don't know if they were
all about him there's just hundreds of
people were calling in for tips he was
on Facebook like on my way to route yeah
he's geo tagging I'm sure what CCTVs too
he's actually a convicted poison Kapil
was a serial poisoner huh I mean that's
a damn dude that's like his thing he's
like I'm maybe I'm reading this wrong
maybe they're calling that him that
because of it yeah like it's a serious
thing that just says just ease justice
yes just because of laws in Germany they
won't identify him scary so we don't
know what he looks like
why I just said because of love I mean
like why do they not okay sure maybe
because of notoriety you know like a lot
of people want to be famous oh you're
smart I thought it was because they're
so like liberal that they're like no we
got to give them their [ __ ] right to
be anonymous it could be that yeah so
the German Court has sentenced him to 12
and a half years in prison and on
charges of attempted murder and
attempted extortion that's it I know a
little bit I feel like it depends on who
you target like babies yeah you should
probably die if you're targeting babies
if you're targeting like other gangsters
and you're a gangster well I don't know
that's okay because those are different
rules you know you're just assassinating
each other do you remember when all
those pet food cans we're killing all
the dogs and then that company didn't
even go out of business which companies
I don't want to say it cuz I kinda wanna
be sponsored by them
ever said that's dope is dumb I don't
even remember that
that's realist Richter
okay I know penny came before you want I
booked a modeling gig with them before
what they dressed you up in a dog come
on all the cat food bags in the Latin
market wait you told me this one oh I
remember the brand Corina yeah was about
not saying [ __ ] but it was one no Purina
owns this oh that's not fake news though
you really model for them yeah I'm the
girl on the bag of cat food like with
the cat but not in America Oh only the
Latin market to Brown for America I'm in
Mexico I'm gonna go check for you bro
yeah well we do want to play them if
they were killing dog well they didn't
mean to kill the dogs but she wants to
buy a house they were I bought a happy
about it with [ __ ] blood money wow
this is some real I modeled for them
before this happened but also they were
they didn't mean to kill dogs and they
decided they're gonna say that Wow she
said they didn't kill any cats like that
made it better because she's a cat
person that's why cuz like they didn't
even go out of business like with pets
being targeted yeah you're a cat person
I am she has to catch the dog person
she's always posting our dogs more than
most cat people are just animal people
they're like they like dogs too but a
lot of dog people are not happy I like
cats I'm just allergic to them I
honestly wouldn't care about cats the
only cat they love or my cat consider
myself a cat person
oh that's how I used to be cuz you don't
like all the cats I don't know what a
cat person is because all you care about
is your cat no cat person is just they
prefer a cat over a dog like if you're
given two choices they're just like I'll
give me a cat forever
well you
I mean want me to dog bit through my arm
when I was little so I mean I never
better because of that but thanks a lot
I love dogs though dogs scratch and they
have big laws that are hurt but they're
like more like dull dogs cuz they're
loud
I just and they're kind of like a lot of
maintenance bit traumatized and you
can't tell your dog your secrets and
it's like in the conversation with the
cats I know my cat looks at me like a
little hidden understand yeah but do you
perform for your cats because I perform
for my dogs all the time and they watch
me like a hottie and my dog would dance
at Tyson my cat riots when you can't be
in the same room as me he gets so
[ __ ] mad he he like beats the door
down and he cries but you don't hear it
because its paws are all fluffy yeah why
do you hear it but I'm like if I let him
in he jumps right on my lap and then he
won't he goes like this to my chest and
he wants to get on my shoulders and he
won't let me do work because you're his
you're his [ __ ] slave and he's like
I'm cold [ __ ] let me like what does he
do when he goes to get Steve he goes to
get Steven he knows it Steve and emails
like family are cut person - I think I'm
good cuz I can relate because my kids do
that it looked like to some degree not
that extreme but it's so freakin cute
like one bit riot especially the boy
he's like way smarter than the little
girl yes I'm the older kind of way
smarter yeah it's like he's always like
now I'm like hey my kitty litter is
dirty I'm not gonna use it I'm gonna
[ __ ] on the floor instead he's he's
telling us first we're so stupid and we
don't get it until after we're like oh
[ __ ] he was letting us know while you're
picking up a [ __ ] from the foot it's a
cat person
just for my cat oh yeah this dude he's
[ __ ] up with the big food [ __ ] this
guy what a [ __ ] hat dude also you could
leave cats for a weekend and you don't
need to be there that's one good thing
about having a cat really cool I have to
pay mad money for a dog sitter
girl even with me oh really they're a
handful and love dogs
I always volunteered a few people's cats
when I go out of town for too long oh
now I know what
if we had a bigger house we could leave
the dogs alone yeah we could it's just
that they bark and stuff so we can just
leave them out there outside dogs aren't
inside but then we have a doggie door so
they can go in and out but because we're
live really close to our neighbors if
we're not home and we don't control how
many times they go out if they hear
something they'll go outside a bar fight
for our strange breed so if we but if we
had a bigger backyard we could probably
be gone for the weekend cuz we had like
to fill the food filler and then the
water and then they'll just hang out
inside if they need a pee they just go
outside on their own they're responsible
with their feedings yeah they're really
responsible they don't get that
separation anxiety I'm sure they do more
than we can only come home they like
missus like crazy
no they don't get the anxiety where
they're crying yeah biting on doors no
another chilling yeah they'll destroy
they just miss you they're just like oh
my god I'm slap your home our old dog
had that he was real oh yeah bark
forever
every time we left the house that's not
look look and then we come home like
eight hours later still but
[Music]